bolsas de arena que estos comerciantes
ponen en los escaparates de las zonas en
riesgo de inundaciones la costa de
Carolina del Sur se está preparando para
la llegada del huracán según las
autoridades se espera que la tormenta
traiga cantidades masivas de agua
especialmente alrededor del mediodía del
viernes
sabemos lo que viene o por lo que hay un
poco de margen de maniobra y Exactamente
lo fuerte que las lluvias y lo fuerte
que el viento será Pero la mayor
variable es la reacción humana
Es que la gente no tome las precauciones
necesarias Ese es el verdadero peligro
que tenemos el error humano
el gobernador de Carolina del Sur insta
a los residentes a tomar en serio la
tormenta frente a los daños
catastróficos que degoían en Florida
donde tocó Tierra como un fuerte huracán
categoría 4 y dejó un panorama desolador
tras las marejadas ciclónicas y los
vientos de más de 240 kilómetros por
hora después de evacuar su casa antes
delgadillan Karen volvió para verificar
el coste de la tormenta
creo que he perdido todo lo que tenía y
estoy tratando de Ser valiente y saber
que mi familia y yo estamos a salvo y ya
me preocuparé de todo lo demás después
no soy la única con una pérdida toda la
comunidad está devastada tenemos que
seguir adelante y empezar un nuevo
capítulo es todo lo que podemos hacer
el gobernador de Florida escrito los
daños como históricos y más allá de las
expectativas iniciales Mientras que el
presidente dubaidon declaró que ya
podría ser el huracán más mortífero en
la historia del estado